If you had to choose between opening up a store
where you worked at the scheduled time or going
to a client’s house to secure a $15,000
deal for your boss, which would you choose?
When he was 23, Mark Cuban faced that very
decision. He chose the deal over the store.
While the choice seemed right to him,
it got him fired. More about that later.
To understand the man behind such bold
decisions, we have to go back to when Mark
Cuban was just 12 years old and sold garbage
bags door to door in a suburb of Pittsburgh.
He later sold powdered milk,
which wasn’t much of a step up.
He recalled in his book, “How
to Win at the Sport of Business”
“In every job, I would justify it in my
mind, whether I loved it or hated it,
that I was getting paid to learn
and every experience would be of
value when I figured out what
I wanted to do when I grew up.”
He figured out very quickly that
he wanted to run his own business.
And boy has he been successful.
From co-founding Broadcast.com,
a pioneer in online broadcasting,
to owning the Dallas Mavericks,
to his iconic role on Shark Tank.
If I offered you $30 million for
the company, would you take it?
Mark Cuban is worth $5.2 billion.
Yet even Cuban grappled with self-doubt
when he started out, admitting:
“In reality, I had as much doubt
as confidence. I was just hoping
the confidence would win over the doubt and
it would all work out for the best.” page 3
After graduating from Indiana University in the
early eighties, he looked for a job where he
could learn more about computers. The personal
computing industry was starting to take off.
He took a job at Mellon Bank in his
hometown of Pittsburgh where he took
old manual systems at small banks and
converted them to automated systems.
He didn’t last long there, all of nine months. His
next stint trying to franchise the TV
repair business lasted eight months.
Then, at the age of 23, he
took off to Dallas, Texas,
where, in his words, he pursued
“fun, sun, money and women”.
He crashed at a friend’s apartment, sleeping
on the couch or the floor, lived off bar food,
and bartended at night while hunting for
a job in the computer industry by day.
He managed to convince a store to hire him to
sell software despite his lack of experience.
When the interviewers asked: “What do you do if a
customer has a question about a software
package and you don’t know the answer?”
He responded, “I would look it up in the
manual and find the answer for them.”
Not only was that a good answer,
but that’s actually what he did.
He’d spend every night reading computer manuals to
learn everything he could about
the products he was selling.
He felt this would give him an “edge” over others.
And he believes his passion for learning is
one of the main reasons he’s so successful.
Clearly, it worked because
customers were so impressed
with his knowledge that they hired him
to install software at their offices.
He charged $25 an hour for consulting,
split between him and the store - and the
extra cash allowed him to move into
an apartment with his own bedroom.
Cuban realized he loved working with technology.
But…he hated having a boss.
Nine months into his new job, a
client asked him to come into the
office to close a $15,000 deal. The
problem was the client wanted him to
come at the same time he was expected
to open up the software store at 9 am
He chose to close the sale
rather than open up shop.
Cuban recalled: “We all have to make that
“make or break” call to follow orders or
do what you know is right. I followed
my first instinct: Close the sale.”
He got a coworker to open up the shop instead,
however, his boss wasn’t impressed and fired him.
While most people would have been crushed by
the firing, Cuban had a different perspective.
He thought:
“...it never really matters how many times
you fail. You only have to be right once.”
Getting fired was a blessing in disguise - it
ignited his drive to start his own company.
He created MicroSolutions, Inc.,
which sold personal computers and
software and helped companies
and individuals install them.
He called up all the clients
he had worked with at the shop,
informing them he was now on his
own, and sought their business.
They were hesitant to hire him since he
didn’t have employees or even a company phone.
So, Cuban's initial approach
focused on building trust.
When he tried to convince one company to buy
an accounting software he was selling, he said
he’d install it for free, and offered to refund
100% of their money if the software didn't work
for them. They’d just need to pay the $500 it took
for Cuban to buy the software from the publisher.
And in exchange, he could use them as a reference.
Instead, he was investing in
building a client base and
reputation, which put him in a better
position to negotiate future deals.
First company, Architectural
Lighting (Cuban thinks he sold
them on Peachtree Accounting)
- they were looking for a time
and billing accounting system to
track their work with clients)
He got along so well with another
client that its CEO, Martin Woodall,
ended up becoming a partner in
his business, MicroSolutions.
They were the perfect match.
Martin was detail-oriented and
“anal” as Cuban described him,
whereas Cuban was disorganized
and not a details person.
Cuban understood that success in business isn't
just about individual talent but also about
surrounding yourself with the right people
who fill in the gaps in your own abilities.
Or in his words, “Don’t lie to yourself. Each of
us has to face the reality of who
we are and what we are.” Page 40
They even weathered a major financial scam when
their secretary stole nearly
all of the company’s money!
Cuban says she whited out the names of the
checks he wrote to vendors and altered them
to her own name, redirecting $83,000
of the company’s $85,000 to herself.
While most people would have
FREAKED out with a capital F,
he didn’t because he thought it a waste of energy.
And the hard lesson he learned was that “No
one was going to cover my obligations but me.”
He returned to work, put his head
down, and searched for new ideas,
reading every book related to
computers that he could get his
hands on - learning about the features that
worked well and the bugs in the software.
He still reads for three hours every day.
After seven years, he sold MicroSolutions in 1990
to CompuServe, a subsidiary
of H&R Block for $6 million.
He took the money and started trading tech
stocks at a time when they were soaring.
It was during this time that he
identified a gap in the digital world
While hanging out with his college buddy Todd
Wagner, they whined about the fact that they
couldn’t listen to the basketball games from
Indiana University while living in Texas.
So, they decided to launch the audio streaming
service AudioNet with just $8,000.
Initially, AudioNet focused on
broadcasting college sports.
Then it went from audio to video -
and this was a decade before YouTube.
AudioNet eventually became Broadcast.com.
They recognized the potential of the
platform beyond sports to broadcast
anything over the internet, including
shareholder meetings and earnings calls.
The idea was to reach people during
the day when they were in the office.
Yahoo! ended up purchasing Broadcast.com in
1999 for a whopping $5.7 billion in stock.
However, Yahoo! would shut down
much of its broadcast services
and Broadcast.com was eventually discontinued.
In hindsight, it’s been called one of the
worst internet acquisitions of all time.
For Mark Cuban, it catapulted
him into the billionaire’s club.
The first thing he did? Was buying a plane.
The asset he values most is time - and his
Gulfstream V business jet bought him more of it.
He didn’t even see it in person
when he bought it online for $40
million - setting a Guinness World Record
for the largest online purchase at the time.
The Gulfstream was just the beginning.
The iconic purchase he’s
most known for was in 2000,
when the diehard basketball made bought
the Dallas Mavericks for $285 million.
What’s that team worth now?
$2.5 billion. Goddamn! EBITDA.
Cuban brought a fresh approach
to NBA team ownership.
He ditched the box seats billionaire owners
were accustomed to and sat behind the bench,
notoriously yelling at the refs.
This hands-on approach also changed the
team’s atmosphere and the Mavericks won
their first NBA championship in 2011.
For Cuban, business is more
intense than any sport.
With sports, you know how long
the game will last, usually.
In business, competition is 24 hours
a day, 7 days a week, 365 days a year.
He once quipped, “If your girlfriend
asks you which is more important,
them or your business, you give the right answer.”
He’s so fired up about competition
that after becoming filthy rich,
he didn’t rest on his laurels.
Cuban launched the high-definition
television network HDNet.
He co-founded the entertainment company 2929
Entertainment, which develops and produces films.
And in 2022, he launched a drug company
that promises steep discounts on hundreds
of prescription drugs to tackle
the high price of drugs in the U.S.
These days, instead of 24 hours a day,
7 days a week, 365 days a year, he’s
cut back…to a mere 18 hours a day.
To spend precious time with his family.
He met his wife Tiffany at
a gym in Dallas in 1997.
They have three children and
live in a chateau-style home
larger than five basketball courts.
When he was young, he’d drive by big houses like
his every weekend and wonder who lived there.
What did they do for a living?
How did they manage to afford a place like that?
The next time you pass by a sprawling estate like
Mark Cuban used to, remember that countless hours,
failures, blood, sweat, and tears
likely paved the way to that doorstep.
Self-education was pivotal in Cuban’s journey,
proving that with the right resources,
anyone can master complex subjects.
And there’s a FREE and easy way to learn.
Brilliant is a website and
app where you can learn math,
computer science, and data science interactively.
Instead of learning in a
stale classroom environment,
you can learn intuitively by working
your way through their puzzles.
I like to spend 10 minutes
a day solving Brilliant’s
logic puzzles to improve my analytical thinking.
You can start at your own comfort level
and then progress to more advanced
lessons. And if you get stuck, you can view the
explanation to discover the correct approach.
You can try out Brilliant for
free for 30 days using my link
in the description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And if you’re one of the first 200 people to
sign up via my link will get 20% off, you’ll
get 20% off your Premium subscription,
unlocking all of Brilliant's courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.